petit gros tracas
sacha elle à répondre à des
interrogations sur le préservatif à des
inquiétudes sur la santé sexuelle ou à
des questions sur la sexualité voilà les
missions de sacha une application
conversationnel basé sur l'intelligence
artificielle
le dernier outil proposé par
l'association hf prévention l'idée c'est
vraiment de pouvoir apporter la
prévention au kilomètre zéro dans ta
poche pour pouvoir effectivement donc
discuter avec quelqu'un de ta santé
sexuelle au quotidien on va donc avoir
des phases où on va connecter les
machines vérifier les données à voir des
médecins qui vont retraités ces
informations apporter différentes
feuilles de langage et puis ça permettra
donc de pouvoir faire évoluer ce achat
sur plus de 800 thématique aujourd'hui
nous avons permis de développer ce qu'on
appelle le comte sellings donc de
dématérialiser les entretiens que nous
faisons habituellement en face à face
avec les personnes là nous les avons
passés en mode dématérialisation 100000
entretien de professionnels de santé
sexuelle ont été intégrées à
l'application sacha un travail sur
plusieurs années avec l'entreprise
prodigieuse filiale de publicis groupe
j'ai eu un rapport sexuel et j'ai peur
d'être enceinte c'était un rapport
vaginal et ça me fait peur sacha en fait
va apporter de l'information
complémentaire va apporter de l'empathie
en se rapprochant en personne en lui
disant ok j'ai bien compris en fait que
tu avais peur mais voilà moi ce que je
peux aider à faire en fait à chaque fois
que quelqu'un va interagir avec sacha on
va décider quel est le message le plus
pertinent jours pour l'accompagner pour
lui donner du conseil mais également
pour l'orienter vers des professionnels
de la descente est disponible sur
smartphone sacha peut être aussi utilisé
sur enceinte connectés l'application
sera disponible aussi sur un site
internet sur alexa ou encore un numéro
de téléphone dédié puis des petits
frères de sacha pourrait aussi naître